[Musique]
messieurs la cour
excentré l'accusé
accusés levez-vous
quels sont vos nom prénom profession âge
et domicile vercammen gustave avocat 31
ans
bruxelles les accusés d'avoir commis un
homicide volontaire sur la personne de
votre femme
reconnaissez vous le fait oui monsieur
le président en fin de l'année en 1886
peut mettre des caméras par la cour
d'assises de seine et de l'entendre m
vercammen reconnaît avoir tué sa femme
il a tiré sur elles cinq coups de
revolver il a donc vraiment voulu la
tuer at-il prémédité son crime vous
aurez à répondre à cela
mais puisque ce soir c'est vous qui êtes
les jurés il ya une question devrait
vous posez sans cesse et cette question
est cet homme at il été aussi naïf est
aussi sincère qu'il le dire à autre
chose l'accusé s'en plaindra souvent à
la presse
au cours de ce procès c'est qu'à cette
époque en belgique comme en france il y
avait un certain nombre de petits
journaux qui pratiquait la violence et
la diffamation et lorsque l'accusé dira
que les journaux de ses adversaires
politiques persécutait il dira la vérité
a dernièrement nous avons changé
il dira mais si les jurés qu'elle a été
le motif de votre crime
monsieur le président je ne crois pas
pouvoir vous le dire avant d'avoir
résumé les principaux moments de ma vie
dit ce que vous pensez devoir dire mais
ne dit que le nécessaire
je dois dire qu'il y a 6 ans j'ai épousé
une jeune actrice alice bruno contre la
volonté de ma famille et de mes amis
tout le monde disait qu alice renault
malgré son jeune âge avait beaucoup vécu
moi je l'aimais et je la croyais plus
nous nous sommes mariés religieusement
d'abord hollande puis civilement en
belgique
nous nous sommes mariés
malgré ma mère qui n'a plus voulu me
revoir malgré mes frères qui monte
exclus de la société que nous avions
formé et malgré mes amis qui m'ont
quitté tous ces sacrifices si je les ai
faits c'est parce que j'étais sûr de la
vertu de celle que j'épouse et vous et
venez vous installer à bruxelles en 1881
aussitôt après votre mariage vous avez
ouvert un cabinet d'avocats à bruxelles
vous étiez tout à fait inconnu vous
pouviez dont y vivre caché votre
mésalliance il serait passé inaperçu
vous avez voulu au contraire par le
biais de la politique devenir un homme
public
un homme dont on parle et ce par des
filles n'ont pas voulu être un homme
dont on parle
je voulais être estimée pour que ma
femme le fut aussi et j'ai voulu mais
élevé dans la hiérarchie de mon pays
afin d'attirer sur ma femme
la considération qu'on lui refusait et
c'est dans cette intention d'ailleurs
que j'ai pris part à la vie politique
vous avez été élu à la chambre en 1884
oui monsieur le président j'avais 29 ans
peu après mon élection j'ai reçu très
souvent chez moi un jeune homme qui
appartenait à l'une des plus anciennes
familles de france le vicomte de
calignac j'avais fait sa connaissance
dirai plus tard comment vous avez fait
sa connaissance
c'est que c'est là un point important
mais votre affaire est si complexe que
je tiens à ce que messieurs les jurés on
est d'abord une vue d'ensemble
vous disiez que le vicomte de galinhas
était devenu votre ami intime
oui c'est exact monsieur le président
sont couverts étaient mis tous les jours
à notre table enfin au théâtre il y
avait toujours une place pour nous dans
sa loge et quand nous partions en
vacances
il venait d'être dit venez avec nous
c'était un homme charmant et je ne
considérais comme un ami sur cette
amitié durera un an
un an exactement le 15 octobre 1884 il
dîner chez nous pour la première fois et
le 15 octobre 80,5
il disparaissait
eh bien je veux dire qu'à cette date le
vicomte de calignac a quitté brusquement
la belgique après avoir vendu à bas prix
des bijoux qu'ils avaient achetés à
crédit
la veille de sa disparition
j'ajoute qu'il me devait 90 mille francs
et quelques jours après le vicomte de
linac a été arrêté à monaco non c'est le
sait son père le comte de gagnac
lui-même qui a voulu porter plainte
contre son fils comment était-il au
courant je l'avais prévenu bartoli devra
continuer une fois en prison galinha qu
écrivait à bruxelles au procureur du roi
pour protester contre son arrestation
dans cette lettre ils m'accusaient
personnellement de l'avoir fait arrêter
il laissé entendre que ma femme avait
été sa maîtresse
il disait même que je le savais et que
je ferme les yeux
comment avez vous eu connaissance de
cette lettre de galinhas au procureur du
roi à calignac avait dû envoyer une
copie à mes adversaires politiques
sonica ya eu erreur journaux pour y
trouver tout
colombie 1 avez vous répondu à ces
calomnies nous avocats m'ont conseillé
de ne pas le faire je leur ai oublié le
6 janvier galinha qui a été transféré à
bruxelles le 12 janvier vous avez
demandé à être confronté avec lui
pourquoi et bien jusqu'au 7 janvier
golinhac n'avez qu'à l'onu somme toute
que ma vie privée
tous les journaux qui mettait au style
le répéter ces attaques était si fier
d'eux et sur dur hier
et moi j'étais si sûr de l'amour de ma
femme que je ne me sentais pas atteint
c'est peut-être parce qu'il s'en rendit
compte le gars lignac cherche à autre
chose
il révèle à ce jour là il avait un
conseiller judiciaire et que je le
savais votre bandits il m'a accusé
d'être le complice de ces escroqueries
nous reviendrons plus tard sur ce point
c'est donc à l'occasion de cette
nouvelle accusation que vous avez
demandé à être confronté avec galinha
président et c'est ce jour là le drame a
vraiment commencé dit ce qui s'est passé
lorsque je me suis trouvé en face du
galinat que je lui ai crié mon
indignation m'a laissé parler
puis très tranquillement il m'a dit je
vous ai apporté ce dossier vous y
trouverez la preuve que votre femme a
été ma maîtresse qui est utile dans ce
dossier des lettres je les ai lus
j'ai été foudroyé ces lettres prouver
tels que votre femme avait été la
maîtresse de galinhas mais aujourd'hui
je me le demande mais ce jour là j'en
étais sûre quelle a été votre première
réaction
j'ai dit à guy lignac il me faut
absolument ces lettres par combien
voulez vous d'argent m'a répondu qu
aussi bien simple signer un papier
attestant que je ne vous dois plus rien
désintéresser les plaignants et je vous
demanderais les lettres finalement vous
n'avez pas accepter ce marché non mais
vraiment frère m'avait conseillé de ne
pas le faire et qui prétendaient que guy
lignac continuerait à faire chanter
c'est à ce moment là vous avez décidé de
divorcer
oui lorsque vous êtes rentré chez vous
après la confrontation
quelle a été l'attitude de votre femme
home a juré qu'elle n'avait pas été la
maîtresse de calignac est là elle a un
elles sont accusées de légèreté de
badinage c'est tout que lui avez-vous
répondu que je ne croyais pas je ne
voulais plus la revoir et devait quitter
notre maison
elle est partie le soir même nom landes
le soir même si moi qui suis partie je
suis à les accompagner ma fille chez mes
frères qui habitent à la dite ce qui
s'est passé dans les jours qui ont suivi
eh bien tous les jours qui ont suivi le
12 janvier
ma femme a écrit des lettres déchirantes
elle mesurait qu'elle n'était pas
coupable d'adultère et elle me supplier
de lui laisser entrevoir un espoir de
partout
off c'était surtout son désespoir qui
m'a bouleversé n'est ce pas que ma femme
je suis malheureuse n'était pas
supportable je ne vous ne vous at il pas
fait une promesse qui prouvait son
attachement son souci d'explication
s'il m'avait promis de ne pas se
défendre le jour du procès elle m'avait
promis aussi de se laisser mon année
c'est vous qui le lui avait demandé
oui dans quelle intention mais pour que
le scandale fut moins grand possible
vous disiez qu'après le 12 janvier votre
femme vous avez écrit des lettres
déchirantes
n'avez-vous répondu à ses lèvres les
cinq premiers jours je n'y ai pas
répondu
le sixième jour je lui ai écrit quelques
lignes de consolation est un peu plus
tard je n'ai rencontré par hasard chez
une cliente
il était difficile de ne pas avoir pitié
d'elle elle était méconnaissable faisait
figuré elle m'a supplié de lui écrire en
me jurant de ne montrer mes lettres à
personne elle m'a supplié aussi de venir
la voir
oui je suis allé une première fois le 22
janvier pour voir si la chambre on avait
loué pour elle était convenable il ne
s'est rien passé de particulier ce jour
là non monsieur le président n'ont pas
je lui dit que nous devions divorcer
parce que mon à normes recommandées mais
je lui ai promis si j'avais divorce ne
pas le faire prononcer par l'officier
d'état civil
ça voulait dire qu'elle pourrait plus
tard reprendre sa place dans votre
maison
c'est cela lui demander quelques années
de patience
cette première visite suivie de quelques
autres madame vercammen habitait rue du
progrès à cette époque le 2 février vous
êtes allé la voir dans la soirée et vous
avez passé la nuit avec elle
oui c'est dont le 2 février que vous
vous êtes réconcilier avec votre femme
vous saviez pourtant et en tant
qu'avocat vous pouviez ignorez vous
saviez que la réconciliation
exclu le divorce - 8 vous le savez
lorsque madame vercammen vous avez
demandé de lui écrire vous saviez bien
que vos lettres pouvait être en
elle-même une preuve de réconciliation
oui ma femme avait promis de nous
montrer ses lettres à personne lorsque
vous alliez voir madame veuve quand même
vous saviez bien pourtant que ces
visites pouvait être en elle-même des
preuves de réconciliation oui enfin ma
femme avait promis de ne pas parler de
ces visites
lorsque vous passiez la nuit c'est
madame vercammen vous saviez bien que
ces nuits étaient en elle même des
preuves flagrantes de réconciliation ma
femme m'a vu juré ne jamais parler de
ses nuits vous savez bien qu'il
suffirait de ne pas tenir sa promesse
pour qu'il vous soit impossible
d'obtenir le divorce
ma femme avait juré qu'elle garderait
secrète cette réconciliation
pourquoi vous êtes vous réconcilier avec
votre femme parce que je l'aimé trop
violemment commencer par et plus
longtemps soit mais dans ces conditions
pourquoi n'avez-vous pas renoncer à
votre divorce à renoncer au divorce mais
c'était impossible monsieur le président
si je n'avais pas été un homme public
si mes adversaires politiques n'avaient
pas imprimé dans leurs journaux
autant de calomnies sur mon compte
certes j'aurais pu pardonner j'aurais pu
renoncer au divorce mais je suis bien
que ces infâmes rumeurs ne doivent pas
être entendus dans cette enceinte
mais rappelez vous monsieur le président
souvenez vous de toutes les accusations
que gagnac avait lancé contre moi selon
lui je je n'étais pas seulement un mari
trompé
j'étais à marie complaisant à maric
avait fermé les yeux
maric avait été bien fier que l'amant de
sa femme fut un vicomte français un mari
qui avait
marie qui avait été content aussi que sa
femme le lutin amant aussi riche
voilà j'étais paraît-il or si j'avais
renoncé
si j'avais pardonner aurait-on dit on
aurait vous le devinez où le devine
aisément on aurait écrit on aurait
proclamé que si je m'étais réconcilier
avec ma femme c'est parce que je savais
qu'elle pouvait prouver que j'avais été
amarré complaisant et mon indignation de
12 janvier on aurait dit qu'elle avait
été fade
voilà pourquoi même secrètement
réconcilier j'ai continué d'un commun
accord avec ma femme a demandé le
divorce
que s'est il passé le 6 mars
je suis allé voir ma femme pour la
supplier de renoncer à faire état de
notre réconciliation
elle n'était pas chez elle elle avait
passé cette journée a répété partout que
nous étions à réconcilier et le résultat
que l'espérer ne s'est pas fait attendre
lendemain les deux avocats qui devait
plaider monde ivars m'ont rendu mon
dossier et dix ans que je les avais
tromper que camatte que je passais
minuit avec ma femme pendant que ma
demande
ils cherchaient à prouver ma culpabilité
sa culpabilité à elle j'étais tellement
effondré que je n'ai même pas cherché à
leur expliquer comment les choses en est
arrivé là
le lendemain je suis allé voir mes
frères qui habitent à lost
je leur ai demandé de m'aider
vous savez j'avais besoin de ré il est
entre nous une scène prix ville m'ont
dit que je ne devais pas compter sur eux
je suis revenu j'ai repris le train pour
bruxelles n'était pas en colère non
j'étais catastrophé
en descendant du train d'acheter un
journal on y annoncer notre
réconciliation est ce que j'avais prévu
arriver les paroles interprétées comme
j'avais pratiquons interpréterait on y
disait que si je m'étais réconcilie avec
ma femme
c'était pour que le jour il divorce elle
ne révèle pas que j'avais été un mari
complaisant or je ne saurais pas vous
dire ce que j'ai souffert en minant cela
moi un mari complaisant alors que
l'infidélité de ma femme avait quitté
mon seul bonheur alors peut alors qu'une
infinité de ma femme avait été le seul
cauchemar de ma vie est justement sur
son bonheur seul souci de ma vie
je suis rentré chez moi j'ai relu les
lettres il m'avait décrite depuis le 12
janvier
je les prie ses lettres je suis allée
chez elle pour lui montrer je voulais
lui dire lit regarde ce que tu m'a écrit
rené tes promesses et à duration redit
ce que tu m'a écrit pour me ramener vers
moi vers toi et dis moi si ce que tu
fais bien
enfin je voulais lui demander de partir
de quitter la belgique pendant quelques
mois
je vais lui demander de ne pas se servir
contre moi de cette réconciliation afin
de donner un démenti public à cette
réconciliation
c'était le seul espoir qu'il restait
avant de vous rendre chez votre femme
vous avez pris votre revolver oui depuis
deux ou trois semaines je prenais
toujours mon revolver lorsque je sortais
tard en arrivant rue verte
ma femme est venue ouvrir je lui ai
tendu de papier je lui dis regarde
l'ivoire et dis moi si ce que tu as fait
bien elle m'a pas répondu
au bout d'un moment elle m'a quand même
dit je vois quoi qu'est ce qu'on dit
dans ce jour là que nous sommes
réconciliés bas c'est vrai non je me
suis assis à côté d'elle et nous avons
posé elle m'a dit je vois bien je vois
bien que tout cela est faux
enfin je ne sais pas comment les choses
se sont passées exactement depuis le
début jusqu'à la fin de l'entretien
je sais que je vais demander de partir
de quitter la belgique
je lui ai dit que c'était le seul
démenti possible pour le donner à notre
réconciliation
elle n'a pas répondu elle a conservé une
attitude froide est récurrente
un certain moment elle m'a dit je vois
bien que tu ne m'aimes plus je vois bien
que tu ne me demandait de golinhac la
véraison en affirmé en affirmant que tu
ne m'as demandé le divorce pour te
débarrasser de moi elle elle m'a dit
elle se dresser devant moi ne s'est mise
à rire
tout d'un coup je ne sais pas comment
les choses se sont passées là elle m'a
dit je suis jeune je suis belle si tu ne
m'aimes pas et bien d'autres m'aimeront
elle a tourné autour de la table l'a
soufflé sur la bougie
alors j'ai tiré je ne sais pas comment
lommel cours et je les ai poursuivi je
sais qu'elle est descendue dans la cave
et si j'avais pu la voir si j'avais si
je n'avais pas été dans l'obscurité je
suis sûr je n'aurais pas tiré sur elle
cit était plus fort que moi c'est quand
la colère qui vous a poussé au crime
oui enfin on m'a mis hors de moi skins
qui ce qui a fait que que j'ai tiré sur
elle c'est la conviction qui m'envahit
c'est à ce moment là qu'elle ne m'aimait
pas ni moi ni mon enfance ce qu'elle
voulait c'était être aimé n'importe où
n'importe partie et elle a même pas eu
un mot pour me consoler on n'a même pas
parlé de mon enfant ainsi aujourd'hui
vous dites que vous avez agi sans
préméditation
cependant la vie de votre arrestation et
même le lendemain vous avez déclaré que
vous aviez prémédité votre crime et que
vous aviez voulu tué votre femme alors
que j'ai su que je l'avais tué j'ai
ressenti l'horreur de la que je venais
de commettre et j'ai voulu accumulés
entre mois comme autant de preuve de
préméditation mais des actes que j'avais
fait spontanément la revenir sur ce
point vous pouvez vous asseoir est entré
le premier témoin monsieur personnes
veuillez lire vos nom prénom âge et
qualité merci mme léon 30 ans agent de
police vous jurer de dire la vérité
toute la vérité rien que la vérité levé
la main droite et jure le jure le 9
avril
à une heure du matin vous étiez en
faction rue de l'université
vous avez entendu des coups de feu vous
avez couru et lorsque vous êtes arrivé
devant le numéro 117 de la rue verte une
femme ensanglantée en est sorti elle est
tombée dans mes bras elle avait la
chemise en veut j'ai éteint le feu sa
chemise était en feu oui une balle il y
avait mille feux en la traversant
l'accusé la suivait alors j'ai mis la
femme un instant sur le trottoir pour
désarmer le meurtrier
il avait encore le revolver à la main il
m'a dit je me rends je suis son époux je
suis vert qu'amène le député la victime
at-elle eu la force de parler oui elle
m'a dit ce n'est pas mon mari qui a fait
cela c'est un inconnu
n'at-elle pas ajouter ne dit jamais que
c'est mon mari oui monsieur le président
avez vous interrogé l'accusé
non monsieur le président mais
l'officier de police est arrivée presque
aussitôt
c'est lui qui a posé les questions
l'accusé vous attiriez indices
pantanella si il m'a dit depuis
longtemps j'avais l'intention de la tuer
et il ajouté il fallait que j'en finis
ce jeudi c'était faux mais si un peu
plus tard il m'a demandé d'envoyer un
télégramme à son frère il a écrit le
texte sur un bout de papier
il a compté les mots on n'avait rien à
ajouter
non
vous pouvez hockey fait entrer le témoin
suivante monsieur le juge charles dit
vos nom prénom et qualité charles
jacques juge d'instruction à bruxelles
vous jurer de dire la vérité toute la
vérité rien que la vérité levé la main
droite et jure je le jure
vous avez été informé pendant la nuit du
8 au 9 avril qu'une personne ne devait
être l'objet d'un attentat
et vous avez été requis de vous rendre
sur les lieux du crime en fm ce
président il était 2h30 du matin quand
je suis arrivé rue verte
je suis entré aussitôt dans la chambre
où madame 20 vercammen était couché les
médecins qui la soignaient était occupé
à extraire les balles qu'il avait reçues
et des tanches et le sang qui coulait de
ses blessures une heure après mon
arrivée et j'ai pu l'interroger
elle a eu la force de vous répondre oui
mais avec beaucoup de difficultés elle
parlait comme les personnes souffrantes
et qui n'a pas beaucoup d'haleine
la victime avait déclaré que l'agent de
police meerson que ce n'était pas son
mari qui avait voulu la tuer savez vous
à partir de quel moment elle a reconnu
que c'était l'accusé qui avait tiré sur
elle à partir du moment où elle a su que
son mari avait été arrêté et qu'il avait
avoué son crime
avez vous réussi à obtenir d'elle un
récit des faits oui vers minuit l'accusé
avait frappé sur la muraille de la rue
de la fraternité
c'était un signal convenu entre eux elle
devait aller lui ouvrir elle était en
chemise elle avait allumé milieu bougies
il y avait alors réclamé des lettre
qu'il avait adressée et qui prouvaient
leur réconciliation
il les avait brûlé dans le foyer et il
lui avait dit qu'elle devait mourir et
lui ensuite
elle y avait alors demandé grâce lui
disant qu'elle était trop jeune pour
mourir
il avait répondu non fêtez prière est
écrit si tu as quelque chose à écrire
il avait alors déchirer les pages d'un
registre où elle noté
toutes les visites que son mari lui
faisait et il avait braqué son aval vers
sur elle elle avait éteint la bougie il
avait tiré un premier coup de feu qu'il
avait atteinte la chemise de madame
verglas mais n'avait pris feu guidé par
cette lumière il avait tiré un second
coup de feu elle s'était enfuie dans la
cave
il avait suivi il avait alors tiré un
troisième coup de feu en l'air pour
faire de la lumière et pour savoir où
elle se trouvait elle s'était bloqué
derrière une porte et ali avait alors
lâché deux autres balles sur elle
comment expliquez vous un tel
acharnement
je crois que la nuit m'avait rendu fou
et et puis comme elle courait jeu
je m'entendais courir je ne voyais pas
qu'elle fut blessé et les contradictions
entre la déposition de la victime et
votre interrogatoire selon le témoignage
de la victime
aussitôt en arrivant vous lui auriez
réclamer les lettres que vous lui avez
écrite et qui établissez votre
réconciliation oui ma femme a déclaré
qu'elle me les avait rendus et que je
les avais brûlé devant elle or on a
retrouvé ses lettres dans sa commode et
elles sont aujourd'hui au dossier et
c'est la preuve même que je ne lui ai
pas demandé et que je n'étais pas brûler
quel est ce registre dont vous avez
déchirer quelques pages
c'était un grand livre sur lequel ma
femme avait tenu le compte de toutes les
visites que je lui avais fait depuis le
début de notre réconciliation et je
crois qu'elle en avait tenu le leconte à
l'intention de son avocat sans doute la
victime at-elle reconnu avoir dit
récuser si tu ne m'aimes plus si tu veux
le divorce et si tu manques de preuves
laisse moi sortir suis moi et dans une
heure tu pourras me prendre en flagrant
délit oui elle m'a avoué qu'elle avait
dit cela son mari parce qu'il la
menaçait et la vdi cela pour éviter
d'être tué et pour avoir une occasion de
sortir
avez vous interrogé l'accusé pendant les
heures qui ont suivi le crime
oui monsieur le président qu'at-il dit
d'important il m'a dit que en partant de
chez lui il avait pris son revolver dans
l'intention de tuer sa femme mais que
cependant
elle avait accepté de quitter la
belgique pendant quelques mois il lui
aurait fait grâce de la vie qu'avez vous
à répondre je vous le dit monsieur le
président je je voulais me punir d'avoir
tué ma femme et j'ai cherché à me rendre
odieux et j'ai voulu faire croire par
tous les moyens à monsieur le juge
d'instruction que j'avais prémédité son
crime pendant combien de temps l'accusé
il reconnu qu'il avait prémédité son
kane pendant une douzaine de jours
oui tant que j'ai su que ma femme vivait
et qu'elles endurent des souffrances
atroces et je n'ai plus voulu qu'une
chose c'est me punir moi même pour tous
qu'elle souffrait après la mort de sa
femme l'accusé est revenu sur ses
premières dépositions la cuisine vous at
il dit qui l avait été son état d'esprit
pendant les semaines qui ont précédé le
crime
oui après son interrogatoire l'accusé
m'a déclaré que depuis le 12 janvier il
n'avait plus vécu normalement ils
avaient été attaqués avec une violence
inouïe par tous les journaux il a vécu
ce sont ses termes exacts comme une
meute de chiens derrière lui il avait eu
des moments de fureur envie de tuer tout
le monde
de cravacher des gens enfin 2 et de se
tuer lui-même enfin il m'a déclaré
plusieurs fois c'est un crime que la
presse sera sur la conscience je
remercie fait entrer le témoin suivant
veuillez lire vos nom prénom âge et
qualité mayence elisabeth 27 ans sans
profession ou juré de dire la vérité
toute la vérité rien que la vérité levé
la main droite et jure je le fais vous
étiez une grande amie de madame
vercammen j'ai habité chez eux pendant
longtemps dans la semaine qui a précédé
le crime
vous allez voir malapert km oui j'y
allais tous les jours de quels faits
avez vous été témoin le mercredi la
veille du crime
j'étais là quand madame de rec est venu
voir alice alain vrai que la tante de la
victime
c'est cela ou madame de rec a supplié
alice d'écouter son mari elle lui a dit
qu'il fallait qu'elle quitte la belgique
pendant quelques temps alice un fini par
dire qu'elle accepterait de partir si on
lui rendait sa fille savez vous si c'est
à la suite de cette visite qu'il a écrit
à son avocat pour qu'ils lui rendent les
lettres de son mari oui c'est après son
départ qu'elle a écrit à son avocat
ainsi la veille du crime
votre femme accepte l'idée de quitter la
belgique c'est à dire de démentir
publiquement par un départ votre
réconciliation elle accepté dans ce
jour-là ce que vous prétendez lui avoir
réclamé en vain le lendemain c'était de
partir à condition que je lui rende
l'enfance qui était impossible n'est ce
pas lui rendre l'enfant s'était
reconnaître la réconciliation quels
sentiments avait-elle pour son enfant
l'aimé beaucoup je crois
le témoin c'était que madame vercammen
n'était pas allé voir sa fille qu'elle
était réconcilié avec son mari c'est
vrai elle n'y avait pas été depuis le
début de février dans deux mois elle
avait le droit d'y aller une fois par
semaine rien vous connaissiez depuis
longtemps le ménage vercammen quelle
était l'attitude de l'accusé vis-à-vis
de sa femme il était toujours aux petits
soins pour elle il ne lui refuse rien et
l'accusé n'a t-il pas accueilli la
famille de sa femme très souvent n'at-il
pas rendu un grand service au frère de
la victime
je sais qui lui a prêté 25 mille francs
le crime a été commis dans la nuit du 8
au 9 avril
madame vercammen a survécu jusqu'au 21
avril
l'avez vous revu après sa mort tous les
jours vous at elle parlé quelques fois
très souvent vous êtes l avouer qu'elle
avait été coupable non elle m'a toujours
affirmé qu'elles n'avaient pas été
adultère vous at elle parlé de son mari
oui elle ne lui en voulait pas elle
répétait simplement
qui aurait cru cela n'a t'elle pas dit
pourtant qu'elle aurait voulu se venger
une fois elle m'a dit je voudrais vivre
pour me venger
des telles pas des nouvelles de son mari
si elle me demandait où il était moi je
lui disais il est en prison
alors elle me disait de veiller à ce
qu'ils me manquent de rien que c'est-il
rien passé à propos d'un portrait de
l'accusé
ah oui dans sa chambre sur la cheminée
il y avait un portrait de son mari moi
j'avais fait exprès de le renverser pour
qu'elle ne le voit pas elle m'a demandé
de le remettre comme il était avant pour
qu'elle puisse le voir c'est ce jour là
qu'elle est mort je reviens
on fait entrer le témoin suivant
les veaux nom prénom âge et qualité non
bio loriot emile 25 employés ou gérer de
dire la vérité toute la vérité et a
mérité levé la main droite et jure je le
jure vous étiez le commis de l'accusé
mais monsieur le président l'accusé
avait il l'habitude de prendre son
revolver lorsqu'il sortait le soir
oui oui monsieur le président depuis
combien de temps avec cette habitude
depuis deux mois environ avant le crime
peut-être un peu plus même savez vous
pourquoi l'accusé pour les son revolver
pour sortir le soir c'était à cause des
attaques les journaux publiés contre lui
il se sentait menacé
l'accusé n'at-il pas demandé au témoin
de la compagnie la passoire
oui monsieur il m'a demandé souvent de
de la compagnie lorsqu'il allait voir
madame ils avaient peur d'être attaqués
et les témoins at il remarqué si
plusieurs personnes les suivait oui
monsieur de deux individus nous suivait
et vous suivez d'assez près une dizaine
de mètres etait-ce pour savoir où se
rendait l'accusé je n'en sais rien ces
gens avait-il une allure menaçante
je ne saurais vous dire fallait il un
revolver vraiment pour se protéger de
ces gens là
tout à fait certain qu'ils existaient
réellement j'en suis sûr j'ai même fait
remarquer à monsieur qu'elle avait
toujours un de chaque côté de la rue aux
quais cilso rejoignait lorsque l'accusé
était temps après dans la maison où
habite de sa femme
oui monsieur oui une fois je me suis
cachée pour voir et bien au bout de
cinquante mètres ils se sont rejoints et
ils ont continué leur route ensemble et
certainement des individus qui cherchait
à savoir si j'allais voir ma femme vous
le savez mes adversaires politiques
avait laissé entendre dans leurs
journaux que je m'étais réconcilier avec
ma femme
mais bien avant qu'elle ait rendu public
notre réconciliation
il est donc certain qu'ils espionnaient
et que c'était là leur argent qui me
suivait ne cherchez donc pas à vous tuer
encore une fois votre revolver me paraît
tout à fait superflue dans cette affaire
je n'aurais pas voulu rappeler dans
cette enceinte violence des attaques
lancées contre l'accusé par la presse de
ses adversaires je ne veux pas citer ces
libelles infâme
ou plutôt je n'en citerai qu'un celui ci
vous connaissez certainement et qui
représente l'accusé pendu haut et court
et vous estimé qu'après ces menaces de
mort m vers cam n était pas autorisé à
prendre un revolver lorsqu'il sortait le
soir alors qu'il était à la merci du
premier imbécile fanatisés par ces
criminels brochure je déplore autant que
vous certainement pas autant je déplore
donc plus que vous si c'est possible
les exagérations d'une certaine presse
mais le fait est que le meurtrier se
trouve de votre côté et n'ont dû leur
part enfin aujourd'hui c'est bien
monsieur vercammen qui est accusé
d'homicide volontaire et non pas
quelconque imbéciles fanatisés par des
brochures criminelle j'ai donc jusqu'à
présent le droit et le devoir de
discuter aussi complètement que possible
des raisons que l'accusé pouvait avoir
de prendre avec lui à revolver lorsqu'il
ce matin lorsqu'ils sortent elles soir
et j'ajouterai que le portrait que le
témoin nous fait de ces espions assassin
me paraît en somme menace
beynat hommage à monsieur le juré
apprécieront monsieur l'avocat général
l'accusation et la défense at elle une
question à poser aux témoins oui
monsieur le président mais à quelle
était la veille du crime et les jours
précédents l'attitude de l'accusé
vis-à-vis de sa femme il était très
accablé
lorsque je lui demandais quelque chose
il ne me répondait que très
difficilement
enfin il ne mangeait plus ou presque il
se soutenait en fumant et cet exemple je
remercie monsieur
dit vos nom prénom âge est hérité moreau
frédérique 32 ans avocat à bruxelles aux
jurés de dire la vérité toute la vérité
rien que la vérité ait levé la main
droite et jure je le jure
vous connaissiez l'accusé depuis
longtemps n'est ce pas oui nous avons
fait nos études ensemble nous étions
très amis dites ce que vous croyez
devoir apprendre à messieurs les jurés
je ne sais si ce que je vais dire est
très important d eh bien lorsque j'ai
appris que vercammen allait épouser une
actrice
j'ai été très surpris pourquoi parce que
je le considérais comme un homme
extrêmement naïf à l'égard du sexe
féminin lorsque nous étions l'université
et qui nous arrivait de discuter de
femmes
il était d'une grande ignorance étaient
même tout à fait extraordinaire sur ce
chapitre
lorsqu'il est arrivé à bruxelles vous
êtes allé le voir oui car ils vous
penserez dès que gustave on croyait tout
ce que sa femme lui disait je dois dire
aussi qu'elle était extrêmement habile
lorsqu'on me demandais ce que je pensais
dell à l'époque je disais ou bien c'est
une fille honnête ou bien c'est le plus
rusé les comédiennes vous savez ce qu'on
racontait sur son compte
on disait que malgré sa grande jeunesse
elle avait eu quelques amants et bien
lorsqu'elle parlait avec moi elle
s'acharnait à défendre son passé mais
comme il y avait certes un fake qu'elle
ne soupçonnait de connaître elle en
était arrivé à imaginer une autre
alice bruno savait qu'elle s'appelait
thalys bruno avant son mariage elle
avait donc imaginer à côté d'elles qui
était alice bruno devenue madame
vercammen une autre alice bruno qui elle
était une fille perdue
un jour je me promenais avec eux elle
m'a pris le bras brusquement me disant
tenez voilà alice bruno qui passe et se
voit qu'elle me ressemble
il y avait en effet une certaine
ressemblance entre hal et bien mais dit
elle c'est celle là dont on a tant parlé
c'est elle qui porte tous les péchés du
monde tandis que moi je suis innocente
et gustave lui croyez cela vous
reconnaissez l'exactitude de ce fait oui
l'accusé vous parle est il de sa femme
lorsque vous étiez seul avec lui oui
dans les confidences qu'il me faisait il
a évoqué sur toutes sortes de fait pour
me prouver qu'il avait épousé une fille
absolument pu me disait par exemple
quelle résistance il avait rencontré
avant de la posséder
vos relations avec l'accusé ont cessé
brusquement
voulez vous dire à quelle occasion un
jour quelqu'un est venu me trouver de la
part de la mère de l'accusé en me disant
que je devais absolument faire un
dernier effort pour détourner gustave de
cette femme
à cette époque il n'était donc pas
encore mariés légalement non c'est le
mariage religieux avait eu lieu cette
personne ne me dit il est certain qu
alice bruno a un amant qui est monsieur
at-elle il faut que gustav ike chez
madame une telle il constatera le fait
il y a des lettres accusés ce sont ces
lettres que l'on a trouvé dans votre
coffre fort oui je les avais découverte
la veille du crime chez moi dans le
secrétaire de ma femme reprenez votre
déposition
avez vous parlé de ces lettres à l'actif
et oui je lui ai répété ce qu'on m'avait
dit il pleura beaucoup je me suis plié
de les faire cette démarche d'aller lire
ces lettres qu'elle me promis de le
faire ils me déclare formellement que si
ces lettres il éprouvait calice n'était
pas aussi pur qu'il ne croyait il rompre
est immédiatement avec elle elle m'a
quittée sur ces mots et le lendemain
matin j'ai reçu une lettre
il me prenait que c'était dans un moment
d'égarement qu'elle avait accepté de
faire cette démarche mais que rappeler à
lui même par la froide réflexion il
avait délibérément renoncé
je suis plus tard qu'à la suite de notre
conversation il était rentré chez lui
extrêmement bouleversée et que sa femme
à qui il avait rapporté ma proposition
l'avait convaincu de ne pas faire cette
enquête à la suite de cet incident j'ai
rompu mes relations non pas avec lui
mais avec son ménage
le témoin n'a t-il pas la conviction que
l'accusé n'aurait pas toléré chez lui la
présence d'un étranger s'il avait écrit
sa femme à fidel je crois l'accusé
incapable de commettre une bassesse et
analyser de façon absolue et en raison
de l' empire que madame vercammen
exercée sur l'accusé pensez vous qu'il
est dépendu de la victime d'empêcher son
mari de la tuer je suis convaincu que si
madame vercammen s'étaient jetés à ses
pieds
il ne l'aurait pas tué quel que fût sa
colère mais quel que fût sa colère il y
a de fait dont je vois je dois vous
parler maintenant rapidement d'ailleurs
pardon lorsque m vercammen vous a donné
tout à l'heure les raisons qui
l'empêchait de divorcer il a oublié de
vous en donner une lavé par la faute de
galinhas 90 mille francs de dettes
seuls ses frères pouvaient le tirer
d'embarras en lui prêtant cet argent or
ils savaient bien que si ses frères
apprenait qu'il renonçait au divorce il
ne l'aiderait pas ils étaient alors
aussi pour cette raison un homme tout à
fait perdu l'autre fait que vous devez
connaître et celui ci un mois avant le
crime le 6 mars gars lignac qui venait
d'être condamné à trois ans de prison
car il n'ya publia une brochure contre
vercammen et la page 32 de cette
brochure a joué dans le mois qui a suivi
cette publication un rôle important
voici ce qu'était cette page 32
yalinga qui prétendait que l'accusé lui
avait dit un jour lorsque je me suis
marié
j'aimais beaucoup ma femme mais je
n'étais pas alors ce que je suis
aujourd'hui sans ma femme et sans ma
belle mère je serai ministre aujourd'hui
aussi jeu là vous aurais dit l'accusé à
calignac aussi je lave ou si un malheur
arrivait je ne regretterai pas et de
galles inea qu'ajouter jeu mais monsieur
vendre qu'amène au défi de jurer sur la
tête de sa fille qu'il n'a pas tenu ce
propos le dimanche 12 avril 1885 rue du
congrès certes l'accusé a juré sur la
tête de sa fille qui n'avait jamais tenu
ce propos
haga lignac pourtant c'est après avoir
lu 7 h 32 que madame berck amènent à
changer d'attitude
à partir de ce jour là elle a cru ou
fait semblant de croire en tout cas que
l'accusé voulait depuis longtemps se
débarrasser d'elle c'est à partir de ce
moment là qu'elle a décidé de tout faire
pour l'empêcher de divorcer j'aimerais
savoir maintenant ce que vous pensez de
l'accusé
doutez-vous de sa sincérité doutez-vous
de sa naïveté
pensez vous qu'il a été un mari
complaisant non sans doute sa femme lui
faisait croire tout ce qu'elle voulait
cela nous sommes tous certes mais nous
allons découvrir maintenant que la
naïveté de l'accusé est beaucoup plus
grande encore si grande même qu'elle
pourra vous paraître suspecte
il nous faut pour découvrir cela revenir
sur ce vicomte dugas lignac qui a joué
dans cette affaire le rôle du diable
c'est peu de temps après votre élection
à la chambre que galinha qui est venu
s'installer chez vous veuillez dire dans
quelles circonstances vous avez fait sa
connaissance deux ans plutôt bien
j'étais au palais et en entrant dans une
salle du tribunal correctionnel
je vis un pauvre bougre qui
s'impatientent ils allaient être jugés
et son avocat n'étaient pas là pour le
défendre
c'est pour vous dire mettez le vicomte
hedegaard gagnac et j'ai pitié de lui
mais il était trop tard pour prendre sa
défense
il fut condamné à quelques mois de
prison pour auquel moitié pour
escroquerie ayant fait appel il me
demanda de prendre sa défense que je
suis volontiers le cas n'étant pas grave
il fut acquitté et aussitôt relâchés
il retourne en france vire tournant mais
entre deux gendarmes la justice
française ayant réclamé pour une autre
affaire d'escroquerie
oui mais pour cette affaire là aussi il
fut acquitté oui en effet mais après cet
acquittement il fut de nouveau jeté en
prison à la requête de la justice
militaire quatre ans plus tôt alors
qu'il était soldat il avait fait un faux
vous l'ignoriez pas ce point si je
l'ignoré n'en avait jamais parlé
voyons avant d'être jugé par le tribunal
militaire et nous a écrit évolué avait
répondu vous avez donc bien adresser
votre lettre à la prison vous saviez
donc il était détenu
ma naïveté va vous paraître énorme
je lui ai écrit et je lui répondu à
l'adresse qu'il m'avait donné monsieur
le vicomte de calignac 42 rue de la
santé et vous n'en avez pas conclu
en prison mais non comme je connaissais
ses récents démêlés avec la justice mme
j'ai pas pensé qu'il pourrait me cacher
quelque chose
aussitôt après votre élection galinha
que vous écris pour vous demander si à
votre avis il pouvait revenir en
belgique et vous lui avait répondu qu'il
pouvait revenir qu'il n'avait rien à
craindre et que vous le preniez sous
votre protection et en effet lorsque
galinha qui est arrivée à bruxelles
vous n'avez pratiquement installé chez
vous comment expliquez-vous que vous
ayez ouvert votre maison à un homme qui
depuis deux ans avait été mis en prison
trois fois pour escroquerie mais
monsieur le président je tiens à répéter
que j'étais au courant de ses deux
premiers procès salma et que ces deux
procès s'était terminé par un
acquittement
ces acquittements signifiant que les
charges relevé contre lui n'avait pu
être établi avec certitude il ne pouvait
pas qu'il était innocent prétendez vous
que vous étiez convaincu de son
innocence
absolument mais enfin j'avais toutes les
raisons de penser qu'il regrettait
profondément ces indélicatesses passé et
qu'ils avaient décidé de se conduire à
l'avenir avec autant de de droiture que
l'exigé le nom qu'il porte est pourquoi
dites-vous j'avais toutes les raisons de
croire parce que les parents de guy
lignac map est écrit et dans leur lettre
ils me demandaient d'aider leur fils à
rester dans le bon chemin
moi j'ai accepté cette mission avec joie
la brussels calignac ne connaissais
personne et je n'ai donc attirer chez
moi pour qu'il ne rencontre que des gens
honnêtes je lui ouvert ma maison pour
lui prouver la confiance que j'avais
dans la sincérité de ces bonnes
résolutions
vous savez ce qu'il a fait de mon
hospitalité c'est à moi qu'on peut leur
reprocher on peut très certainement en
tout cas vous reprochez votre
aveuglement
vous saviez bien que très vite la
présence continuelle chez vous de gagnac
a suscité des commentaires malveillants
et vous n'en avez tenu aucun compte
votre aveuglement était si intense que
dans l'acte d'accusation doutent de sa
sincérité
on se demande si cet aveuglement n'était
pas de la complaisance mais je pense que
des témoins pourront vous promets vous
prouver ma bonne foi galinha cas portés
contre vous
une autre accusation qui met en cause
votre honorabilité galinha qui avait un
conseil judiciaire
vous savez monsieur le jury qu'un homme
pourvu d'un conseil judiciaire n'est pas
civilement responsable sa signature ne
vaut rien ses engagements non plus or
galinha qu affirme que vous saviez qu'il
avait un conseil judiciaire lorsque vous
lui avez fait ouvrir un crédit chez vos
fournisseurs
de ce fait vous vous rendiez complices
de ces escroqueries moment fait c'est
une calomnie monsieur le président si
j'avais su que gas lignac avait un
conseil judiciaire mais jamais je ne
l'aurais présenté à mon banquier ou n'y
a personne comme un homme qui on pouvait
avoir confiance et rien ne laissait
supposer que gagnac et un conseil
judiciaire et non son père lui envoyer
des sommes d'argent considérables tous
deux pouvaient vous prouvez que vous ne
saviez pas que galinha qu'avait un
conseil judiciaire
ah mais parfaitement au mois d'octobre
dernier
yalinga comme écrivait je crains comme
le four un conseil judiciaire
et dans cet aveu qu'il me faisait c'est
la preuve que je ne le savais pas mais
monsieur le président cette lettre est
au dossier fait entrer le témoin suivant
jusque le docteur daury
lille vos nom prénom âge et qualité dori
max 50 ans docteur médecin bruxelles
vous jurer de dire la vérité toute la
vérité rien que la vérité levé la main
droite et jure je te jure
vous avez bien connu le ménach de
l'accusé oui monsieur le président
j'étais leur médecin depuis le jour de
leur mariage
pensez vous que l'accusé ait pu
soupçonner l'existence de relations plus
ou moins légère entre sa femme et gagna
la conviction absolue qu'ils n'avaient
aucun soupçon
j'en ai vu souvent la preuve au cours de
l'année dernière il est venu plusieurs
fois me consulter chez moi à chacune de
ses visites je lui ai fait quelques
observations sur la présence trop
assidus de galinhas chez lui je lui dis
que j'étais certain que madame vercammen
n'était pas coupable qui mais qu'il
fallait tenir compte de l'opinion
publique et que vous répondez t-il
il était certain de l'honnêteté de sa
femme et de l'inanité de ces bruits elle
lui avait d'ailleurs juré qu'il n'y
avait jamais eu la moindre chose entre
galinha qu elle est que galinhas ne
possédait pas la moindre lettre audel
comment expliquez-vous que l'accusé est
une si grande confiance en lui à linac
alors qu'il connaissait son passé
judiciaire
mais difficile de répondre à votre
question monsieur le juge vous étonner
de la confiance des raisonnable que
l'accusé réduire un gars lignac
je ne crois pas moins que l'accusé avait
tant regali n'y a qu'une confiance
déraisonnable je crois qu'il lui faisait
confiance par de voir si vous voulez
parce qu'il estimait que son devoir
était de tout faire pour que galinha ne
devienne définitivement honnête homme
ainsi la conduite de l'accusé s'explique
parce qu'il faisait confiance à guy
lignac et qu'il avait confiance à sa
femme
exactement cela je vous remercie d'avoir
si bien compris les raisons on
aveuglement est ce que le comte et la
comtesse de galinhas ne sont pas venez
vous faire une visite quelques jours
avant de repartir pour la france 6 et
leur fils d accompagner et il ya eu une
discussion entre nous ou plutôt entre
eux et un moment donné modem de galinha
qui s'est levé avec une certaine
vivacité l'a demandé à son fils mais
enfin oui ou non madame vercammen était
la maîtresse il a répondu
catégoriquement non et madame degas
lignac a conclu je l'espère bien car je
veux croire que tu ne ferais pas dîné ta
mère la table de ta maîtresse et lignac
nakiele d'ailleurs pas protesté contre
ces bruits oui il m'a dit qu'il sera le
dernier des misérables s'il avait trompé
quand même mais je tenais au mois de
mars dernier
madame vercammen est allé quelques jours
à pailles et galinier qui l'avaient
accompagné
je m'étais opposé à ce voyage parce
qu'elle était à ce moment là en mauvaise
santé et l'accusé s'est dit lui aussi
opposé un voyage parfaitement
elle est partie malgré lui et malgré moi
madame vers quand même chose et tout ce
qu'elle voulait vous pensez donc lorsque
l'accusé a laissé partir sa femme pour
paris en compagnie de guy lignac
il n'avait pas le moindre soupçon j'en
suis convaincu
si je me suis reposé à ce voyage ce
n'est pas par méfiance c'est parce que
ma femme n'était pas en bonne santé j'ai
une part et c'est dangereux pour elles
de se fatiguer quel était l'objet de ce
voyage à paris re et soeur de ma femme
allait accoucher et je crois qu'elle
avait besoin d'argent et mon beau frère
était en faillite malgré les 25000
francs que je lui avais prêté il menacé
d'être expulsé de chez lui ma famille
est inquiète et je comprenais son souci
d'aller aider sa soeur
vous voyez donc qu'au départ en tout cas
il ne s'agissait il ne s'agissait pas
d'un voyage de plaisance non le dossier
que gas lignac a ouvert devant vous le
jour de votre confrontation avec lui n'y
avait-il pas en dehors des lettres qui
prouvait que vous avez été trompés n'y
avait-il pas une pièce concernant ce
voyage au mois de mars à paris
s'il y avait une note d'hôtel
alors que je la croyais installé chez sa
soeur ma femme avait pris une chambre à
l'hôtel duel d'air et galia qui étaient
descendus dans ce même hôtel et la note
que ce misérable avait conservé me
prouve que s'ils nous avaient chacun
leur chambre bain pour n'est pourtant
certains repas en commun dans une de ces
deux chambres ayant lorsque madame
vercammen est revenu à bruxelles après
le séjour à paris n'at-elle pas été
gravement malade chez et quelle a été
l'attitude de l'accusé lors de cette
maladie il était très inquiet et très
affectueux mais le témoin croit-il qu'à
ce moment là j'aurais pu dire à
galinière comme il a affirmé dans sa
brochure
mais si je n'avais pas épouser alice
bruno j'aurais pu être ministre et que
par conséquent je ne je ne regretterai
rien si un malheur devait arriver je
suis sûr que vous n'avez pas dit ça
depuis il ya accusé m'a constamment
confié qu'il ne souhaitait réussir dans
la carrière politique que pour relever
sa femme dans l'esprit de la famille
berkane
ils voulaient forcer sa mère et ses
frères a estimé sa femme c'est là l'idée
qui anime et sa vie je suis le gars
lignac a menti parce qu'il a écrit dans
sa brochure que vous souhaitiez la mort
ou la disparition de votre femme madame
verts qui amène avec elle une grande
influence sur l'accusé elle avait sur
lui un pouvoir absolu merci vous pouvez
vous
témoin suivant monsieur pense dit vos
nom prénom âge et qualité bronces
léopold 38 ans favori aux jurés de dire
la vérité toute la vérité une vérité
levé la main droite et dit je le jure je
le jure l'accusé a fait souvent appel à
vous depuis sa confrontation avec kenya
enfin je veux dire depuis le 12 janvier
oui dans les heurts mêmes qui ont suivi
la confrontation
il m'a fait appeler pour que je rédige
la requête en divorce j'avais commencé
la requête par ces mots le scandale qui
vient d'éclater
il m'a demandé de les biffer à cause de
sa fille disait-il il voulait justement
que le scandale n'éclate pas c'est pour
cette raison qu'il a demandé à sa femme
de ne pas se défendre
pourquoi selon vous madame vercammen
appelle d'abord accepter de se laisser
condamner
je crois que c'est pour attendrir son
mari pour l'émouvoir plus tôt pour qu'il
commence à lui pardonner qu'elle avait
promis de ne pas défendre le jour du
divorce elle lui avait écrit pour te
prouver mon attachement pour expier les
fautes
je t'ai juré de me laisser condamner
l'accusé vous êtes il dit à partir de
quel moment il a pensé à se rapprocher
secrètement de sa femme non non il ne me
l'a pas dit expressément mais que je
crois que c'est une lettre de fin
janvier qui responsable de ce
rapprochement
elle lui écrivait c'est la fin de la
phrase que je vous ai cités à l'instant
pour te prouver mon attachement jeter
juré de me laisser condamner
message bien qu après notre divorce je
ne serai plus jamais at war cette menace
a bouleversé l'accusé il n'a pas pu
supporter l'idée que sa femme puisse
vivre et se refuse à lui mais je crois
l'accusé vous êtes il dit comment la
réconciliation c'était fait
non monsieur non non je lui ai demandé à
plusieurs reprises s'il avait été
victime d'une surprise ou d'une
séduction mais il ne m'a pas répondu
ne voulez-vous pas répondre aujourd'hui
je ne comprends pas votre question nous
vous demandons si votre réconciliation a
été le fait d'une surprise d'une
séduction de la part de votre femme je
n'ai jamais été étonné de séduit par la
faune quelle occasion l'accusé vous êtes
il a appris qu'il s'était réconcilié
avec sa femme
c'est un jour qu'il m'avait demandé de
l'accompagner chez elle je pris congé
assez rapidement et comme j'allais
sortir j'entendis sa femme crier je t'en
supplie gustave remet ses lettres et je
suis revenu sur mes pas quelles étaient
ses lettres sur le moment je l'ignorais
mais c'était des lettres qui avait été
écrite à l'accusé à sa femme avant
depuis leur réconciliation des lettres
qui pouvait permettre à madame vercammen
de prouver qu'ils étaient réconcilier
des lettres qui suffisait à annuler la
procédure de divorce car je le rappelle
à messieurs les jurés la réconciliation
exclu le divorce
eh bien ces lettres vercammen les tenait
à la main il y avait du feu dans la
cheminée il aurait pu les i je t'ai et
détruire ses preuves il ne l'a pas fait
il les a remises à leur place en disant
à sa femme
ces lettres appartiennent je ne peux pas
les reprendre
c'est ce jour-là en sortant de la rue
verte que j'ai dit à l'accusé
j'ai la conviction que tu es réconcilier
avec elle il m'a répondu oui c'est vrai
et depuis que la réconciliation a eu
lieu elle fait un chantage continuel
elle me menacent d'aller trouver mon
avocat et de lui remettre les lettres
que tu as vu pourquoi avez-vous rendu
célèbre au lieu de les détruire
monsieur grosse vous a répondu ces
lettres ne m'appartenait plus à quelle
époque se place la scène que vous venez
de décrire
le conseil de discipline et des dents
saisie de la ferme
oui je rappelle à mes séries jury que le
30 mars à la suite de certaines
accusations portées contre lui par
galina qu vercammen a comparu devant le
conseil de discipline de l'ordre des
avocats ne vont pas entrer dans les
détails de cette procédure puisque
vercammen a été acquitté nous devons
expliquer quelles incidences pouvait
avoir la réconciliation de l'accusé sur
la décision du conseil de discipline
l'accusé peut-il dire lui-même quelles
étaient ses incidences parfaitement guy
lignac portées contre moi des
accusations de nature différente mais
qui rejaillissait l'une sur l'autre
en fait c'était ma bonne foi qu'il
mettait en doute de toutes les manières
et c'était donc ma bonne foi que je
devais prouver
alors ma femme on aurait empêché si elle
avait révélé notre divorce sans doute
c'est pour prouver votre bonne foi que
vous deveniez a divorcé quoi exactement
il c'est pour cette raison que les jours
qui ont précédé la session du conseil
l'accusé m'a supplié d'intervenir auprès
de sa femme pour qu'elle garde le secret
ce qu'elle a fait oui vous voyez bien
que votre femme vous à mais comment
alors que vous étirer congrès concilier
depuis deux mois elle acceptait de ne
rien dire et cela uniquement pour vous
permettre de prouver votre bonne foi
qu'elle renoncement et vous pour votre
défense vous sacrifier votre femme
mais comment n'avez-vous pas compris que
l'on vous aurait cru le jour du conseil
de discipline
si vous aviez dit voilà j'aime ma femme
j'ai cédé à un besoin de mon coeur je me
suis réconcilié avec m si vous aviez dit
cela
croyez vous vraiment qu'on ne vous
aurais pas cru j'ai eu en effet l' envie
de révéler la vérité la veille du
conseil de discipline j'ai écrit à ma
femme je lui ai demandé
penses tu que je dois venir demain que
nous sommes réconciliés et bien
savez-vous ce qu'elle m'a répondu vous
vous dire que le même et elle qui trois
jours plus tard allait remettre mes
lettres à son avocat elle m'a répondu
non il ne faut rien dit c'est à cause
d'elle que j'ai marty être un jour plus
tard il me trahissent et
l'offre pourquoi selon vous votre femme
vous at elle dit non il ne faut rien
dire mais parce qu'elle voulait garder
pour elle le bénéfice de la catastrophe
elle voulait continuer à me faire
chanter est ce l'avis du témoin je crois
qu'il est impossible d'être d'un autre
avis je reviens une dernière fois sur le
point de savoir si l'accusé a été de
bonne foi ou non sur le point de savoir
s'il a été la dupe où le complice de
galinhas votre conviction maintenant
doit être fait
vous pensez sans doute que m quelques
semaines a été sincèrement naïve mais
même si vous êtes sûr de sa bonne foi il
vous reste à évaluer sa culpabilité
at-il prémédité son crime at-il
sacrifier sa femme son orgueil at il tué
parce qu'il devenait fou à force d'être
trahi le réquisitoire et la plaidoirie
vont nous expliquer différemment au très
différemment
le crime de l'accusé qui toutes ont
d'abord sur l'avocat général le 12
janvier
c'est la confrontation
vous apprenez que vous avez été trahi
vous chassez votre femme et vous
demander immédiatement le divorce ce
jour là vous êtes inflexible messin
jours après voici déjà ce que vous
écriviez à votre femme alice jamais je
n'aurais de maîtresses ni de femme tu
resteras toujours ma femme devant dieu
explique ce passé qui m'a plus
cruellement atteint que toi sois
consoler pauvre femme comme dieu je
serai bon mais je ne puis pas te garder
auprès de moi
nous devons divorce et lit les journaux
soient consoler pauvre femme comme dieu
je serais vous comme cela est beau
cela serait magnifique si c'était
sincère mais le mensonge et là je te
pardonne mais nous devons ont divorcé
c'est à dire je te pardonne mais je n'ai
pas le courage de mon amour
je t'aime mais je n'ai pas le courage de
me réconcilier avec toi lis les journaux
c'est à dire je courbe le front devant
cet ouragan que la presse a déchaîné
contre moi cet ouragan
je n'ai pas le courage de l'affronter et
quelques jours après vous vous
réconcilier avec votre femme que
reste-t-il de vaud soupire de votre
colère voici ce que vous écrivez le 4
février chez alice
j'ai été très heureux pour la première
fois depuis le 12 janvier j'ai mangé de
bon appétit
gardons le silence je te défend de ne
rien dire à personne du secret que je
t'ai confié qu est-ce que ce secret que
vous lui avez confiées c'est ce pacte de
route et de duplicité que vous avez
établi ce jour là vous avez dit à votre
femme pour le public
tu restes la femme déshonoré pour qu'il
n'y a pas de pardon mais deux doigts
mois la réconciliation est complète et
la nuit je me glisserai futur
furtivement auprès de toi car vous
voliez votre femme mais vous ne vouliez
pas sacrifier pour elle votre position
politique ni votre situation au barreau
voilà ce que je ne pardonnerai pas à
l'accusé pendant que vous êtes là ses
pieds presque tous les soirs vous
organiser un vaste système de mensonges
et de duplicité à l'intention de votre
famille à peine et vous réconcilier avec
votre femme que vous simulez pour vos
frères une série de démarches tendant à
prouver qu'elle est adultère est
coupable le 4 février vous dit cheikh
hallil j'étais très heureux et voici la
lettre que le lendemain vous adresser à
votre frère
j'ai interrogé le cocher de gagnac
il prétend ne s'être aperçus de rien si
ce n'est de quelques familiarités comme
entre frère et soeur mais demain je
compte aller à east
j'espère être plus heureux vous espérez
être plus heureux c'est à dire que vous
comptez ramassés à east
des témoignages qui accableront votre
femme pardon qui accablent
l'autre parce que quand vous écrivez à
votre frère c'est ainsi que vous parlez
de votre femme l'autre et elle a dit
vous vous sortez de chez elle et vous
l'appelez l'autre remarquez bien
messieurs les jurés cette duplicité
pour la famille il imagine une poursuite
de la femme adultère et à la femme
adultère
il fait quoi au pardon et à la
réconciliation
messieurs les jurés je viens de vous
montrer les verts qu'amène trompant ses
frères le voici maintenant trompant ses
juges le 30 mars vous comparaissez
devant le conseil de discipline de votre
homme vous êtes là devant vos pairs
qu'allez vous faire dire la vérité
avouez que vous vous êtes remis avec
votre femme non et pourtant je ne crois
pas me tromper en affirmant que si vous
vous étiez présenté devant les juges de
votre ordre avec votre femme au bras
l'acquittement que vous avez obtenu vous
eûtes été plus sur nantes accueille
encore qu'allez-vous faire au lieu de
tout cela vous fait s'accabler votre
femme vous l'art présenté comme la
dernière des misérables et vous sortez
ses bras vous écrivez à votre frère j'ai
contre ma femme une telle haine que si
je la rencontrais je serai capable de
l'étrangler en pleine rue et vous sorti
de ses bras et vous voulez que cette
situation se prolonge jusqu'au 10 avril
parce que c'est le 10 avril que l'on
doit apaiser votre divorce mais après
votre acquittement par le conseil de
discipline
votre femme se lasse de jouer ce double
jeu elle veut obliger prétendez-vous à
renoncer au divorce n'est ce pas vous
qui tout le premier avait renoncé au
divorce en acceptant de vous réconcilier
avec elle qu'elle vous demande de
reconnaître les faits un point c'est
tout alors vous comprenez que votre
duplicité va éclater vous comprenez que
vous êtes un homme perdu et vous dites
voilà l'oeuvre ignoble de ma femme
et bien non ce n'est pas votre femme
c'est vous même qui vous êtes mis dans
cette situation désespérée car ce n'est
pas votre réconciliation clos vos
proches
c'est d'avoir dissimulé si vous l'aviez
proclamé le premier jour on aurait pu
croire on aurait cru qu elle vous avait
été dictée par un élan de votre coeur
par un amour insurmontable mais comment
voulez vous que l'on puisse croire à
votre sincérité
alors qu'on apprend tout cela est tout à
la fois et votre réconciliation et votre
duplicité et nous en sommes arrivés à la
veille du crime
c'est le jeudi soir que vous allez tuer
votre femme
le mercredi soir vous sentez que la
catastrophe approche vos avocats vous
ont rendu votre dossier
plus personne ne veut vous défendre vous
ne pouvez plus divorcer la nuit du
mercredi au jeudi les témoignages sont
formels sur ce point vous l'a passé chez
votre femme vous l'acquittez vers 7
heures du matin vous rentrez chez vous
vous brûler des papiers comme si vous
alliez mourir comme si vous alliez tué
vers la fin de l'après midi vous vous
rendez à lost
vous allez voir vos frères vous avez
besoin de leur aide pour régler vos
dettes
il vous met à la porte quoi de plus
naturel vous les avez trompés vous leur
avez joué la comédie du divorce en
quittant le train qui vous ramène
d'alost vous acheter un journal et vous
y trouvez votre réconciliation
interprété comme vous aviez prévu
qu'elles le seraient pour éviter le
divorce
le mari complaisant se réconcilier avec
sa femme est alors au lieu de vous en
prendre à vous même à votre duplicité
vous allez chercher votre revolver et
vous allez demander à votre femme de
partir de quitter la belgique pour
prouver au monde entier que vous n'êtes
pas réconciliés messieurs les jurés
souvenez vous de ce que tout à l'heure
madame mahias nous a dit la victime
acceptait de partir à condition qu'on
lui rendit son enfant vous ne croyez pas
en sa sincérité
alors pourquoi est elle était demandé à
son avocat de lui rendre les lettres de
son mari
ces lettres qui était la preuve même de
leur réconciliation si vous n'avez pas
été sincère pourquoi aurait-elle
redemander ces lettres
donc madame vertommen accepte de partir
mais l'accusé refuse de lui rendre son
enfant pourquoi mais parce que pour
sauver son mari pour donner un démenti
formel à leur réconciliation
il importe comme à l'âme vers cam elle
continue à jouer le rôle de la femme
coupable à qui l'on n'a pas pardonné or
on n'en pas son enfant à une femme
coupable et c'est à ce moment là que le
drame éclate
madame vercammen ne veut pas partir sans
sa fille madame vercammen ne veut pas
donner au monde l'image de la femme
adultère fuyant bien humblement le juste
courroux de son mari et bien qu'elle
meure et vous l'a tué cruellement vous
vous acharnez contre elle elle s'enfuit
vous la poursuivre et vous dirait une
fois deux fois trois fois quatre fois
sympa toutes les balles de votre
revolver voulait tirer contre l ai voulu
vous ne conservez pas une pour vous
votre crime accompli
vous êtes calme vous envoyer un
télégramme votre frère et vous comptez
les mots voilà l'homme au passion
irrésistible
messieurs les jurés
souvenez-vous de la clameur qui s'est
élevée dans le pays tout entier lorsque
le 9 avril on nous a appris que vers
qu'amène avait tué sa femme
ce jour là messieurs les jurés avez vous
entendu une seule voix proclamer qu'il
avait bien fait qu'il se trouverait
quelque fois quelque part en belgique
un jury capable d'innocenter un pareil
forfait sous peine de substituer le
droite aux crimes allant pire des lois
sous peine d'encourager les pires
violences vous ne pouvez pas hésité un
seul instant vous devez condamné verte
amen c'est ce que je vous demande avec
une entière confiance
la parole est à la défense
quand on veut la raconter simplement
cette histoire est très simple il y à un
premier drame celui du 12 janvier celui
de la confrontation avec galinha qu il y
à ces lettres plus que prouve tels que
galinha qui a été l'amant de madame
vercammen non jeu mais monsieur l'avocat
général au défi de trouver dans le
dossier une seule preuve d'adultère
et pourtant ces lettres sont une insulte
un affront l'accusé demande de divorce
quand il la chasse de la maison
conjugale
madame vercammen ne proteste pas ne
pense qu'à demander pardon et les
criques à l'accusé des lettres
déchirantes le supplie de lui répondre
et lui répond il lui répond ali ce thème
est heureuse je ne la cus pas d'avoir
dès ce moment prémédité tout ce qu'elle
allait faire non je pense qu'elle est
heureuse simplement qu'il est accepté de
lire ses lettres il lui demande de venir
la voir elle l'appelle vous comprenez ça
messieurs les jurés
cette femme qu'il a aimée contre tous
cette femme qu'il a épousée contre tous
cette femme l'appelle et lui dit je ne
suis pas aussi coupables que tu le crois
et il va la voir il me répète que les ti
naissante et le lui répète si souvent il
se prend à espérer
inspiré que le jour du divorce elle pour
approuver cette innocence et qu'elle
reprendra sa place dans la maison et
c'est cet espoir qui le fait rester avec
elle le soir du 2 février une partira
qu'au matin il n'y a eu aucun désaccord
entre eux cette nuit là
où est la duplicité que monsieur
l'avocat général nous montrait du doigt
à en croire l'accusation allait place
cette duplicité le lendemain le 3
février
l'accusé et tri à ses frères désignant
sa femme
l'autre était là et commence un dit
monsieur l'avocat général
il vient de passer la nuit avec sa femme
et il l'appelle l'autre et il annonce
qu'il va partir pour est afin de trouver
des preuves d'adultère eh bien oui c'est
vrai monsieur il l'appelle l'autre il
valait s pour enquêter
monsieur l'avocat général a oublié de
vous dire qu'à l'aube de cette nuit de
reiki conciliation madame vercammen
avait complètement changé d'attitude
alors que la veille encore elle demande
humblement le droit de prouver son
innocence
ce matin-là savez-vous ce qu'elle
demande
elle demande à l'accusé de renoncer au
divorce
et savez-vous ce qu'elle fait elle va
voir son avocat et lui raconte tout
voilà ce que l'accusation avait oublié
de vous dire elle va voir son avocat et
lui révèle ce qu'elle avait juré le
garder secret trouvez vous normal
maintenant qu'il appelle l'autre une
femme qui a changé si vite quand la
duplicité monsieur l'avocat général si
elle existe elle n'est pas de notre côté
en tout cas rien je saute maintenant au
30 mars
ce jour-là m vers kamel doit comparaître
devant ses pairs il lui faudra prouver
sa bonne foi mais des bruits courent
déjà on parle de cette réconciliation
il faudra donc la démentir il est pris
de scrupules ils hésitent
il demande conseil à qui à sa femme
malgré tous ces revirements il lui a
gardé sa confiance
si elle pense il doit faire éclater
cette réconciliation il ne fera ils s'en
remettaient mais lui dit non il faut de
terre et il se tait ils m'ont devant le
conseil de discipline
il est acquitté aucune sanction ne sera
prise contre lui ne sera pas radié du
barreau
mais puisqu'il a menti puisqu'il a
certifié qu'il n'était pas à concilier
ils doivent aussi levé son divorce que
sa femme avait accepté en lui
conseillant de mentir
et voilà que le lendemain elle exige de
son mari qu'il renonce définitivement à
ce divorce alors il réalise brusquement
le chantage
il comprend que cette femme lui a
demandé de se taire pour mieux conserver
son pouvoir sur lui il comprend qu'elle
l'a trahi il n'y a pas d'autre mot et
messieurs les jurés voilà l'explication
de ce drame d'avoir été trahis par celle
ans qu'il avait mis sa confiance jusqu'à
la dernière minute
c'est un frôle la folie on vous l'a dit
ils ne mangent plus il ne dort plus il
est traqué par la presse par les
calomnies et de pluie et abandonné
tromper mais c'est à ce moment là qu'il
écrit à ses frères
si je rencontrais ma femme dans la rue
je crois que je l'étranglé ray vous
voyez monsieur l'avocat général a oublié
de mettre dans leur contexte les lettres
qu'il nous a lu je ne connais pas le
très long plus cruel que celles dont la
victime s'est rendue coupable
cette traîtrise est si grande que
l'accusé petit croire les fous de ne pas
y croire certes je voulais dit qu'il
était fou et quand il vient lui demander
de partir quand il vient lui dire que
c'est la seule chose qu'elle peut faire
pour lui il n'a pas encore compris
qu'elle ne voulait rien faire pour lui
depuis longtemps
et quant à ce dernier refuse et lui
lance ses mots si odieux pour lui qu'il
a tant aimée mais si tu veut des profs
des tuiles terre suis moi tous les aura
dans une heure c'est le drame
messieurs les jurés la loi qui vous a
chargé de la mission redoutable que vous
avez à remplir la loi vous dit appeler à
votre aide votre raison et votre
intelligence votre conscience et aussi
votre coeur à messieurs j'ai un dernier
témoin à faire comparaître devant vous
rappelez vous cette femme agonisante
dans sa chambre sur la cheminée est là
le portrait de l'accusé
une mamie l'a renversée au qui ne lui
laisse pas les yeux lorsqu'elle s'en
aperçoit elle dit
remettez en place le portrait de mon
mari et elle demande de ses nouvelles
elle s'inquiète de savoir s'il ne manque
de rien s'il n'est pas trop malheureux
est la pitié de lui
messieurs les jurés vous montrez vous
plus sévère
voici les deux questions qui ont été
posées aux jurés l'accusée vercammen
gustave ici présent est il coupable
d'avoir dans la nuit du 8 au 9 avril
1886 volontairement commis un homicide
sur la personne d'alice bruno son épouse
deuxième question y at il eu
préméditation
on y jurés
le faire connaître la décision du jury
sur mon honneur et sur ma conscience
devant dieu et devant les hommes
la déclaration du jury est à la première
question oui l'accusé est coupable à la
seconde non il y a des circonstances
atténuantes accusé levez-vous
la cour après en avoir délibéré vous
condamne à 15 ans de travaux forcés
ce verdict a été cassé on l'a découvert
en effet qu'il y avait eu un vice de
forme
l'un des jurés n'étant pas absolument
belge vercammen a donc été jugé une
seconde fois et cette seconde fois là la
défense n'a pas été aussi galante
qu'aujourd'hui elle a présenté la
victime comme une gourgandine presque
c'était plus adroits malgré cela
vercammen a été condamné mais à dix ans
de travaux forcés seulement au lieu de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]